Esse vídeo foi editado inteiro pelo
Cloud Code, rodando o Oppul 5.5, mais
novo modelo da Antropic, e conectando a
Higsfield a ele. Eu gravei de uma vez,
não abri em nenhum momento o programa de
edição. Os movimentos saíram da
Remotion, que é uma skill gratuita que
você pode instalar no Cloud Code,
Remotion Best Practice. Esse movimento
de zoom devagar que se aproxima de mim
quando eu falo alguma coisa importante.
O punk atravessa toda a cena, esses
movimentos de câmera, a folha de papel
passando em frente, a tela que troca o
fundo e esses recortes de papel caindo
na tela com sombra, com textura, com
cara de colagem feita à mão. Não dá para
você desenhar isso em código. Essa parte
quem criou foi a Hickfield e quem
decidiu o que entrava em cada segundo
foi o Opus 5. Que segurou um trabalho de
dezenas de etapas do começo ao fim, sem
perder o contexto. Hoje eu vou te
mostrar como tirar o máximo também
dessas skills gratuitas, a Remotion e a
Watch Vídeo. Depois eu vou chegar a um
vídeo profissional com qualidade de
estúdio conectando o plugin da Rigs são
dois níveis diferentes. No primeiro, só
com skills gratuitas que você pode
começar a utilizar hoje mesmo dentro do
Cloud Code. E no segundo nível nós vamos
tirar essa qualidade de estúdio
conectando ao Cloud Code o plugin da
Higsfield. E você não precisa saber
programar nem entender de edição. Você
descreve o vídeo a forma que você quer,
com linguagem natural e o Cloud como
diretor conectado a essas skills e a
Higsfield monta o vídeo para você a
partir de uma pasta vazia. Então, para
esse vídeo, o que nós vamos utilizar é
aqui o Cloud Code. E já apareceu aqui
para mim a nova atualização do Cloud
Oppo 5.5. Ele acabou de atualizar, então
eu vou clicar aqui em experimente agora
e eu já vou ver que ele tá como padrão,
o Oppul 5.5 aqui e no esforço médio, que
é onde tá o melhor custo benefício desse
novo modelo. O novo modelo Dantico,
Oppul 5.5 veio como padrão esse nível de
esforço médio. E eu já rodei aqui vários
testes nesse esforço médio e o resultado
tem sido excelente. Não precisa ir para
o nível alto ou extra alto aqui. É você
aumentar muito pouco o nível do seu
resultado e ter um custo muito maior.
Então eu já criei aqui na minha área de
trabalho uma pasta chamada estúdio.
Dentro dessa pasta eu coloquei apenas um
único vídeo. Então é uma pasta vazia,
não tem nenhuma skill instalada. Nós
vamos começar o processo do zero. Então
voltando aqui no Cloud Code e você
precisa verificar se você tá no ícone de
fato do Cloud Code Desktop. Você tem
aqui essa versão ao lado que tem o chat
e o callwork, o mesmo que você costuma
utilizar na web. E aqui ao lado você tem
o cloud code, que é onde nós vamos estar
utilizando. Agora a primeira coisa que
nós vamos precisar fazer é selecionar
essa pasta que nós criamos, que está
aqui na área de trabalho. Basta você
selecionar ela uma única vez e
selecionar essa pasta, o Cloud vai
perguntar se você confia nesse diretório
que ele vai trabalhar, vai manipular,
criar todos os arquivos. Vou clicar
aqui. Confio sim. E agora sim, a gente
já pode ver que estamos dentro desse
diretório, dessa pasta que vai virar o
nosso projeto, o nosso estúdio com tudo
instalado. Aqui eu quero fazer o
processo do início. Então nós vamos
fazer uso de duas skills que são
gratuitas nesse primeiro nível. A
primeira é essa remotion. Eu já tenho
alguns vídeos aqui no canal falando
sobre a remotion. Ela dá uma direção
completa. Essa skill, ela é muito mais
completa do que as pessoas imaginam. Ela
não é só para fazer algumas edições, ela
tem aqui mais de 300 efeitos que ela
consegue fazer, transições também,
efeitos avançados de transição. Ela é
muito completa. Eu vou entregar aqui
também esse material com todo o manual
das possibilidades, porque quando você
sabe tudo que ela consegue fazer, você
consegue fazer o melhor uso dela. E eu
quero entregar isso hoje para vocês
também. Uma outra skill que nós vamos
precisar aqui para esse projeto é essa
daqui que vai ser os olhos para o nosso
OPO 5. Para nós começarmos a criar
vídeo. Aqui o Oppus 5. Ele não só
transcreve o vídeo, tanto vídeos do
YouTube quanto vídeos localmente. Então
aquele vídeo que nós temos aqui nessa
pasta no computador, nós conseguimos dar
o caminho para o Cloud Code, transcrever
esse vídeo, não só transcrever o vídeo
com todos os tempos de fala, porque vai
ser muito importante pra gente conseguir
dar ao Cloud Code, que vai ser o diretor
desse nosso estúdio de edição de vídeo,
vai dar ao Cloud Code esse tempo de
fala, vai dar o Cloud Code a direção de
onde que cada elemento precisa acontecer
e no momento certo que precisa
acontecer. Mas ter só transcrição não
bastaria. Imagino que você tenha um
vídeo dinâmico que você fala e tem
diferentes cenários. Por exemplo, a
watch vídeo, ela também tira os frames
de cada momento de fala e você pode
ajustar isso no prompt. Você pode tirar
frames a cada 4 segundos, 8 segundos, 16
segundos ou a cada segundo. Fica um
pouco mais caro, mas o preço é centavos.
Eu, quando eu instalei no primeiro
momento, eu fiquei até recioso de fazer
uso dessa skill, imaginando que ficaria
muito caro fazer a transcrição e os
frames, mas na verdade isso tudo é feito
em script de código. Então aquilo que é
exercício da LLM do OP 5, na verdade
custa centavos, que é apenas ela mandar
rodar um script para poder fazer toda a
transcrição e todos os frames do vídeo.
Então essa skill watch Vídeo, ela é
essencial para dar essa direção também
visual para o Cloud Code, pra gente
poder fazer a edição de vídeo. Eu vou
fazer esse processo do zero com vocês,
mas eu já deixei aqui esse repositório
que eu vou disponibilizar para vocês. Eu
acabei de criar para entregar hoje para
vocês. É um repositório completo que já
une essa direção para o Oppo 5. Uma
direção também para a Remotion, a Watch
Vídeo e também com a Higfield em dois
níveis de edição. É um repositório que
tá público, tá? Você pode instalar, você
pode fazer um fork e editar esse
repositório na forma que você achar
melhor. E ele tá aqui com uma licença
MIT, então você pode utilizar, você pode
comercializar se você quiser. E aqui a
gente já tem dois níveis de edição, que
é o que nós vamos fazer nesse tutorial
de hoje. Primeiro nível, edição com
código puro, e um segundo nível usando o
plugin da Higsfield. E toda a direção
você já tem aqui. Então basta você
copiar o link desse repositório e voltar
aqui para o cloud Code e você vai pedir
para ele clonar esse repositório. Mas
agora aqui tem um ponto importante, não
basta você falar para ele clonar, você
vai pedir para ele clonar e ler o
arquivo Readm, que é onde está as
instruções do que ele tem que fazer. Tem
várias dependências aqui. São duas
skills e isso é uma forma simplificada
da gente poder passar num tutorial, mas
aqui para essas duas skills funcionarem
tem vários outros arquivos, vários
plugins que ela precisa instalar para
ela funcionar de forma perfeita. Então
aqui dentro desse arquivo readm desse
repositório, eu já deixei todas essas
instruções que quando seu OP 5.5, seu
agente lê, ele já vai saber como fazer.
Então aqui basta você pedir para ele, eu
vou mandar aqui o pedido, clone para mim
esse repositório dentro dessa pasta, mas
antes de clonar, leia o arquivo readidm
que está dentro desse repositório,
porque lá estão todas as instruções para
você montar a pasta conforme instruído
pelo autor. Vou mandar aqui então esse
pedido. Agora, a partir disso, ele vai
montar todas as dependências da forma
que você precisa. E depois que você
tiver clonado esse arquivo, você pode
fechar o Cloud Code uma vez e abrir para
garantir que todas as dependências,
todas as skills vão ser reconhecidas na
próxima sessão. E entrando aqui, você
vai ver uma pasta como essa daqui desse
meu diretório que eu já tenho o clone do
estúdio, que é o que nós vamos utilizar
hoje. Eu vou aumentar aqui um pouco a
visualização para você ver um pouco
maior. E são essas pastas que nós vamos
ver aqui dentro desse projeto. O que nós
temos aqui? Um primeiro arquivo
cloud.md, MD, que é onde tem as nossas
skills, as instruções, onde tem também
esse arquivo de edições, que é para onde
vai o produto final da edição. E nós
temos aqui essa pasta de projetos, que é
onde nós vamos entrar com o projeto, com
aquele vídeo bruto que nós vamos mandar.
Então, aqui tem um primeiro projeto, ou
seja, você vai ter uma pasta para cada
projeto, para cada vídeo que você vai
editar. E da mesma forma aqui dentro
dessa outra pasta de edições, vai
aparecer uma subpasta de cada vídeo
editado. Então na pasta de edições vai
chegar o vídeo final já editado com
todas as inserções, com as montagens,
transições, os cortes, o produto final
do vídeo. E aqui dentro de projetos vai
entrar o vídeo bruto, uma pasta para
cada projeto para você manter a
organização. Essa pasta é onde o código
vai acontecer. Essa pasta chamada src a
remotion trabalha criando todas as
inserções. E dentro aqui do nosso
cloud.m, que é o cérebro de toda essa
operação, é onde tem todas as
instruções. Então, um primeiro nível,
que é o nível gratuito, 100% gratuito,
com as skills gratuitas, que você pode
fazer muita coisa. E o segundo nível é o
nível que nós estamos chamando de nível
de estúdio para você poder ter uma
qualidade de um criativo, algo muito
mais elaborado, que nós vamos chegar
aqui no exemplo do vídeo. Você pode
olhar com calma, fazer alguma adaptação,
porque esse arquivo cloud.m MD é aquele
arquivo que o Cloud ele vai ler sempre
que você começar um novo projeto. Ele lê
aquilo, é a instrução dele para ele
saber como trabalhar. Então eu vou
voltar lá na área de trabalho que eu
tenho o meu vídeo bruto. Eu vou dar um
conttrl X aqui nesse vídeo, voltar aqui
na nossa pasta. Como eu falei para
vocês, dentro aqui dessa pasta de
projetos é onde nós vamos entrar. Então,
como normalmente eu faço, eu abro uma
nova pasta, eu vou dar o nome dessa
pasta de estúdio, que é o exemplo que
nós vamos usar nesse vídeo. E agora
dentro dessa pasta, eu vou colar aqui o
vídeo bruto, que é a gravação que eu
fiz. Ele tem alguns silêncios, ele tem
aqui algumas pausas, ele é um vídeo já
com corte bruto e não tem nenhuma edição
do início ao fim. Você vê que é eu
falando na frente da tela sem nenhuma
edição. É a partir desse arquivo que nós
vamos voltar aqui no nosso cloud code.
Então, qual foi a primeira mensagem que
ele me mandou aqui por meio desse ask
user question? Quando você manda uma
primeira requisição, ele lê o cloud.m
que você quer fazer agora. Então aqui eu
vou responder que eu quero fazer um
primeiro nível de edição, que é a edição
do nível um, ou seja, gratuita a partir
das skills remotion, as skills watch
vídeo também, os plugins, as ferramentas
FFPEG, ferramenta de transcrição de
vídeo, ou seja, um pacote aqui dentro
desse repositório para fazer uma edição
a partir de código puro. aqui a partir
dessa primeira automação, então ele vai
preparar o ambiente pra gente poder
começar a fazer esse nível nesse
primeiro nível. E ele já começou aqui o
processo. Note que eu nem tinha falado,
você vê que já apareceu aqui, tava o
vídeo e agora eu já tô ouvindo aqui o
meu computador trabalhando. Deixa eu até
voltar aqui. Isso, ele já começou o
processo em execução. Uma tarefa em
execução. Qual tarefa de execução?
Python script. O que que ele tá fazendo
agora? Ele reconheceu o vídeo é 01 que
eu anexei lá dentro da pasta e ele tá
fazendo já a transcrição desse vídeo, ou
seja, já o processo automático. Ele
ainda não vai começar a edição. Depois
ele vai me perguntar aqui algumas
coisas. Ele tá dizendo: "Já comecei a
transcrever o vídeo palavra por palavra,
depois vou assistir todos os quadros e
propor duas ou três edições para esse
vídeo. Enquanto isso, me diga o que você
quer." Então, é aqui que a gente vai
mandar o prompt para ele para dizer o
formato que a gente quer. Só que
descrever algo nesse nível é muito
difícil. Então, quero ver o que que a
gente consegue fazer aqui com o OPO 5.
Criando vídeo com código pluro. Então,
eu vou colocar aqui essas imagens de
referência. São imagens de clipe de
papel que tem uma identidade um pouco
mais humanizada, né, que que foge um
pouco dessa estrutura de A. Então, esse
é um vídeo que eu vi aleatório na
internet e tem essa esse formato de
papel cortado, né? Então, eu quero fazer
uma animação seguindo mais ou menos essa
identidade visual. Voltando aqui no
Cloud Code, eu tô vendo que ele já
terminou o processo de transcrição. E eu
já tô vendo aqui no primeiro processo,
ele transcreveu e a transcrição
automática, normalmente ela reconhece
cloud como sendo nuvem, né? Porque a
pronúncia correta do cloud seria cloud.
E quando a gente fala diferente, mas
pelo contexto, ele já reconheceu e ele
já mudou isso automaticamente na
transcrição. Ele fez a transcrição lá na
pasta, criou essa pasta de transcrição.
Aqui dentro da pasta de transcrição, eu
já posso ver o nosso vídeo todo
transcrito. Então o cloud ele precisa
disso daqui para poder fazer a direção
completa do que que vai entrar e o que
vai entrar, quando que vai entrar, o
movimento da câmera. Ou seja, já temos
aqui um processo inicial pra gente poder
começar essa edição. Voltando aqui, ele
já fez esses ajustes e agora ele já tá
me dizendo aqui os prints que podem
fazer falta. Eu já copiei esses prints
lá na pasta, mas ele tá me dizendo aqui
para jogar esses prints dentro da pasta
que ele criou aqui. Então, como eu já
fui copiando os prints depois, ele já
foi trabalhando, na verdade ele
antecipou, né? Então eu vou jogar aqui
esses prints para essa pasta de prints.
E agora temos então um arquivo bruto de
sequência, temos a transcrição que ele
já fez. A partir disso, nós já temos
quase tudo que nós precisamos para
começar o nosso processo. Só falta os
frames. Ele não faz isso de forma
automática, porque nem sempre você vai
precisar tirar frames dos vídeos. Às
vezes é só uma narração que você quer
fazer, uma animação, uma apresentação.
Então a gente já pode colocar isso no
prompt na hora de pedir para ele fazer o
vídeo. Eu vou mostrar para você como eu
faço de fato na prática na hora de criar
um vídeo. Quanto maior o contexto,
quanto mais você consegue descrever o
que que você quer que aconteça, ali é um
vídeo explicando exatamente esse
processo, as skills que eu uso. É um
vídeo que eu vou postar no shorts ou nos
re. Então eu vou descrever para ele o
que eu quero que aconteça no vídeo.
Então a partir desse vídeo que você já
transcreveu na pasta, você vai fazer um
único frame, porque eu mantenho a
posição do início ao fim desse vídeo.
Pode tirar apenas um único frame para
você ver como eu estou posicionado na
câmera. E você vai construir todos os
movimentos, toda a dinâmica do vídeo de
acordo com a minha fala. Então, na
medida que eu vou explicando aquilo que
acontece, as skills que eu uso para
poder editar o cloud como diretor, dê
uma identidade ao cloud code Oppul 5
como diretor, use um frame que tem um
print, na verdade, que tem na pasta, que
eu tô demonstrando exatamente a
identidade visual do lançamento do Alp.
Tem que ter essa mesma identidade visual
nessas animações e também essa
identidade de recorte de papel. Então,
faça parecer orgânico, natural para que
o vídeo aconteça de forma como um
tutorial, uma demonstração de todos os
elementos acontecendo. Na medida que eu
vou falando, você vai montando as
ilustrações. Em alguns momentos pode ter
tela cheia, em outros momentos tela
dividida, em outros momentos apenas as
ilustrações que você vai criar para
poder dar essa variação. Faça transições
leves entre a tela cheia da
demonstração, entre o momento que você
vai dividir a tela mostrando. Pode ser
um quadro com a minha câmera, com meu
rosto um pouco menor, enquanto você vai
mostrando as coisas acontecendo na tela,
entrando os elementos de forma dinâmica
para que todo o fluxo seja interessante,
envolvente do início ao fim. Então esse
é o prompt. Então assim, eu não descrevo
exatamente aquele prompt. Eu não faço,
na verdade, um metaprompt dizendo para
ele exatamente o que tem que acontecer
em cada segundo, porque eu quero dar
essa liberdade criativa. Então, isso é
uma coisa que eu coloco no final do meu
pedido. Essas são as minhas instruções
de forma geral, mas não se restrinja a
elas. Se você vê alguma coisa que vai
ficar mais interessante, melhor, você
tem a liberdade criativa para poder
modificar ou adicionar algum elemento
que eu não tenha citado nesse pedido. Eu
já vou mandar esse pedido para ele. Essa
parte final do prompt é onde a partir
ali do Opus 5, os modelos começaram a
ficar tão bons que quando você pede para
ele fazer algo que você não estava
pensando ou te indicar, te apontar
alguma coisa que talvez você não estava
vendo, um ponto cego seu, é onde o
agente te surpreende. Então ele vai
agora rodar o processo e agorinha a
gente vai ver o resultado desse vídeo
montado completo lá na pasta. E a partir
desse pedido, ele levou aqui uns 2
minutos e criou esse plano de edição.
Então você pode olhar com calma esse
plano de edição e ele sempre vai
trabalhar dessa forma, mesmo aqui nesse
primeiro nível usando a remotion e a
watch vídeo. Ele criou aqui algum plano,
o que que vai acontecer em cada momento,
o que faz sentido e qual o tipo de
animação que ele vai criar. Então, hora
vai ser câmera, ou seja, tela cheia,
hora vai ser uma notícia, um print. Hora
vai ser uma câmera dividida como se
fosse uma imagem, como uma apresentação,
na verdade, né? Quando você tem uma
imagem e a tela pequena do lado, você
tem biroll também, que são as animações
apenas em tela cheia. Em cada momento
você pode ajustar de acordo com a
numeração. Aqui ele fez o gancho, que é
a fase inicial, ele identificou que é um
vídeo como se fosse desses vídeos curtos
até o CTA final, que é um dos estilos de
edição que a gente tem dentro desse
repositório. Então aqui eu quero já
aprovar direto esse projeto. Eu vou
dizer aprovado. E ele vai continuar a
edição a partir desse plano. Se eu
quisesse modificar alguma coisa, essa
seria a hora aqui. Lembrando que esse
primeiro nível ele tem algumas
limitações, já é muita coisa que você
consegue criar, mas ele não faz, por
exemplo, algumas animações que a gente
faz no nível dois. Mas eu quero editar
exatamente o mesmo vídeo pra gente ver e
comparar lado a lado qual é o resultado
que você tem usando esse processo e
usando o nível dois. Agora sim, ele já
terminou toda a edição. Ele levou quase
20 minutos para fazer tudo. Eu tô vendo
aqui o processo, a cadeia de pensamentos
de toda a edição. Ele criou todo esse
storyboard aqui antes de fazer a edição.
Eu fui acompanhando aqui pro vídeo não
ficar muito grande, mas mostrando aqui
agora para vocês. Ao longo do processo,
o Oppo 5. Ele já foi gerando uma imagem
inicialmente e corrigindo aquela imagem
quando sair alguma coisa fora do frame.
E ele foi ajustando isso para evitar
retrabalho pra versão final que sai na
pasta. Agora eu tô muito curioso para
ver o processo aqui. É o nível um de
edição. Ele já fez tudo isso 20 minutos.
Eu achei interessante. Ele seguiu aqui
aquela identidade visual que a gente
colocou lá na pasta. Abrindo aqui agora
na pasta, ele tirou os frames para ver a
posição do rosto na hora de dividir tela
para não ficar fora do frame. Então ele
pegou todas essas amostragens aqui antes
da edição. E como eu falei para vocês,
esse projeto ele acontece do início ao
fim, onde esses arquivos brutos eles são
editados aqui dentro dessa pasta
projetos. E voltando aqui agora na pasta
principal do estúdio, a gente vai ter
essa pasta aqui de edições, que agora
sim ele criou essa nova pasta, onde nós
temos aqui esses frames, ou seja, aquele
storyeboard que ele criou, que nós vimos
lá também dentro do cloud code. E agora
sim, apenas o arquivo final MP4 com a
prévia da visualização aqui. Agora eu já
vi que ele criou também uma legenda. Eu
não dei nenhuma instrução específica de
formato de legenda, então eu quero ver
qual formato da legenda que ele criou.
Então a gente vai ver aqui agora o
resultado final. dessa edição. Tô muito
curioso para ver como que ficou a edição
desse vídeo. Eu vou tocar ela aqui
agora. Agora dá para editar um vídeo com
cara profissional, sem abrir o programa
de edição nenhum. Eu uso para isso
quatro peças. A primeira é o Code
rodando o Opus. A identidade do
lançamento do Opus 5 que tinha esse
frame na pasta, ele criou para gerar,
>> ele é o diretor. Ele leu o que eu quero,
decide o que cada trecho do vídeo
precisa, chama ferramenta.
>> Aqui ficou um pouco fora do frame, mas
às vezes acontece, era possível ajustar
isso no prompt também. O frame do vídeo
nesse momento ficou um pouco cortada a
parte certa e o que ela deve fazer. E o
Opus 5. Ele aguenta um trabalho comprido
desses, do primeiro corte até o render,
sem esquecer o que eu pedi lá no começo.
E a segunda peça é a watchvíde, uma
skill que dá olhos ao cloud, o fundo com
a identidade visual do corte de papel,
agora montando o storyboard com a
legenda sincronizada segundo a segundo
no momento animação é tudo na rem
daquele vídeo inteiro. E aí ele manda
para o cloud code para ele planejar
todas as inserções de acordo com a
posição que eu estou no vídeo. A
terceira, nossa, isso aqui ficou muito
bom aqui, muito acertado. de acordo com
a posição que eu tô no vídeo que eu
estou e ele cria o frame da posição, que
é exatamente o formato que ela edita.
Ela pelos frames que ela tira naquele
começo do vídeo, eu pedi só alguns,
então por alguns movimentos, então
acabou saindo em algumas horas, mas se
você pedir para ele criar o frame eh do
início ao fim, esses erros, né, que ele
pode fazer de acordo com o movimento ou
se você tiver cenas diferentes, é bom
você pedir todos os frames naquela etapa
inicial ou no prompt edição inicial para
ele não errar esses enquadramentos no
vídeo. A terceira peça é a remot, a
skill que monta tudo isso. Ela corta os
silêncios, faz as transcrições, os
movimentos de câmera, coloca texto na
tela, decide onde eu fico em cada
quadro. E como tudo isso é código, eu
mudo qualquer coisa depois, sem precisar
refazer tudo de novo. E uma dica que
mudou os meus resultados é, em vez de eu
tentar descrever o estilo do vídeo que
eu quero, eu mostro para ele um exemplo.
Eu separo um vídeo e a idade visual aqui
a partir de código. Qual que é a grande
diferença? E esse repositório tá
disponível para vocês, tá pessoal? Isso
tudo é no nível um de criação. Esse é o
repositório que ele já tá montado. Por
que que eu montei esse repositório para
entregar para vocês? Porque no último
vídeo que eu gravei mostrando o processo
que eu faço para usar remotion a watch
vídeo, algumas pessoas travaram na hora
de configurar o cloud.m. Aqui nesse
repositório tá tudo pronto para você
poder criar esse primeiro nível de
vídeo. Aqui a minha opinião honesta
sobre esse formato de gravação tem
alguns elementos aqui. Quem entende de
edição, mais do que eu, eu não sou
editor de vídeo, mas aqui você pode ver
que ele já pega o arquivo em MP4, ele
cria inserções no formato overlay. Ou
seja, antes, eu já uso essa skill há
bastante tempo, antes dessa skill, a
gente precisava criar esses arquivos
separados e depois unir esse ao nosso
arquivo principal esses overlays. Ou
seja, já era muito útil, mas aqui agora
ele mesmo já faz esse processo e tem os
arquivos prontos no formato final.
Então, a identidade visual, qual que é a
grande diferença aqui? Está exatamente
naquela etapa inicial onde ele pede uma
referência visual. aqui é o que faz, é o
8020 do projeto. Todas essas animações
dá já uma dinâmica muito legal.
Inclusive, pessoal, eu não lembro de
nenhum vídeo aqui antes do OPO 5.
Legendas animadas. Então, imagina, você
pode colocar no prompt inclusive qual
tipo exato da legenda você quer que ele
cria. Então, não precisa nem mais baixar
aqueles pacotes de letters animados.
Aqui ele já faz isso para você. Agora,
eu confesso que tem algumas coisas,
apesar da identidade visual dá esse tom
bem único, tem algumas coisas que você,
se você é um editor, você vê que às
vezes fica um pouco fora, né? Causa
alguma, alguma impressão que alguém que
é mais exigente, assim, um editor mesmo,
que entende de After Effects, edição de
vídeo, talvez se incomodasse, mas aqui
já é muito melhor do que qualquer coisa
que eu conseguiria fazer. Eu edito os
meus próprios vídeos. Eu já trabalhei
com coprodução usando o Premiere Pro,
editar curso, mas nada desses elementos
de motion gráficos eu conseguia fazer.
Isso era muito caro, na verdade. Alguém
que era editor de motion graphics, era
uma sala especial ali dentro do estúdio
e o cara cobrava caro para poder fazer
essas coisas que você pede e o Cloud
Code cria com código. Agora, pra gente
avançar no próximo nível, eu tô aqui com
a conta da Higsfield aberta. Agora eu
quero ver. E aqui é uma comparação
honesta e fiel, porque eu quero ver como
que vai ser esse mesmo projeto editado
agora conectando a Higsfield, porque ali
com o OPO 5.
Muito bom. Eu sei que eu não conseguiria
fazer um projeto naquele formato. Mas
agora como que a gente conecta então o
nosso Cloud Code lá? O projeto ele já
está pronto. O cloud ele já sabe que a
gente vai utilizar. O que que nós vamos
fazer? E você precisa também para poder
conectar. Eu vou fechar aqui o cloud na
web, essa sessão, até porque essa sessão
ela já tá aqui com uma janela de
contexto em aproximadamente
228.000
tokens. Ou seja, todo esse processo nós
gastamos 23%
da janela de contexto do Oppo 5.5, que é
de 1 milhão de tokens. Então aqui um
pouco, né, um processo, um vídeo de 2
minutos com todas essas animações. Foi
esse o processo total, 20 minutos aqui
de trabalho. Agora você fecha a o seu
aplicativo porque nós vamos instalar,
nós vamos, na verdade, conectar o plugin
da Higsfield aqui no nosso setup. Aqui
dentro do cloud já logado na minha
conta, você vai em personalizar. Dentro
de personalizar, você vai na aba de
conectores. Aqui em conectores, você vai
pesquisar por Higgsfield. Aqui vai
aparecer a opção nesses primeiros, já
apareceu aqui para mim. Estando
conectado a sua conta da Higsfield
normal pela web e também a sua conta do
Cloud Code no mesmo navegador. Ao clicar
aqui em conectar, ele vai te levar para
uma autenticação OAL ALF, uma vez que
você já está conectado e permitindo aqui
uma primeira vez, ele já vai reconhecer
a Higsfield em todos os sistemas, tanto
no cloud na web quanto no cloud aqui
também pelo aplicativo desktop. E antes
de nós mandarmos o pedido prompt, é bom
a gente perguntar se o MCP da Higstível
nessa sessão logo depois que você faz a
conexão. A primeira conexão, ele vai
buscar o MCP, ele confirmar se aqui
dentro do aplicativo do Cloud Code a
gente já tem o MCP disponível. E ele
está dizendo aqui que sim. Então nós já
estamos com o nosso cloud Code OPO 5.
Higsfield. Agora nós já podemos começar
o nosso projeto lá na pasta. Eu criei
essa nova subpasta da Higsfield, onde eu
coloquei exatamente os mesmos prints e o
mesmo vídeo original para fazer essa
mesma edição e ver qual será o, ou seja,
nós vamos mandar o mesmo vídeo, a mesma
referência visual usando o mesmo sistema
e o mesmo modelo, o OPO 5. No esforço
médio aqui para poder criar esse novo
vídeo. Agora eu vou mandar para ele o
mesmo processo, mas pedindo para ele
fazer já a edição do nível dois. Se você
não fala nada, ele te manda aquele ES
user question. Se você já coloca no
prompt, a tendência é que ele já faça a
edição completa. Então eu vou mandar
aqui para o meu editor como eu quero que
seja feita essa edição. Dentro dessa
pasta do projeto 002, nós temos um vídeo
que foi gravado na vertical. Eu quero
que você use a Higsfield com todas as
ferramentas de edição, de imagem e de
vídeo que tem dentro dela para criar um
projeto dinâmico com esse fluxo e a
identidade visual. que eu coloquei
dentro dessa pasta 002. Essa identidade
visual não é para restringir o modelo, é
para ser uma referência visual daquilo
que você pode criar. A fala, eu vou
explicando aquilo que eu quero que
aconteça ao longo do vídeo. Você vai
criar um storyboard, o broll, todos os
elementos seguindo a edição para ela
ficar toda dinâmica, mostrando em forma
de cortes de papel, fazendo transições
de imagem, mostrando a tela um pouco
menor, reduzida, aumentando, mostrando a
tela cheia apenas com o birow da
animação, fazendo também uma divisão de
tela para que fique animado enquanto
você ilustra aquilo que está acontecendo
na tela. Você tem a plataforma inteira
na mão, pode utilizar ela para fazer
essa edição completa do início ao fim. E
já vai processar esse prompt aqui. Eu
confesso que ele ficou um pouco mais
simples do que o primeiro que eu mandei,
mas ele vai entender e dentro desse
projeto ele já tem as instruções daquilo
que ele pode fazer. Então já vou mandar
esse pedido aqui, nem vou revisar o
pedido, ele vai usar e seguir todo o
fluxo e editar o vídeo na pasta dois.
Ele já identificou aqui que o conteúdo
na pasta dois tem identidade e a
referência visual. E ele já começou o
processo novamente com Fester Whsper
para poder fazer a transcrição. E nós
vamos ver o processo acontecendo todo de
novo pra gente ver o resultado agora sim
do vídeo de nível de estúdio. Espero que
fique de fato nesse formato diferente.
Ainda não sei o resultado que vai ser.
Tô muito curioso para ver. Aqui sim uma
comparação mais realista. mesmo modelo,
mesmas referências visuais, o mesmo
vídeo, o que é possível fazer com o
plugin da Higsfield e o que é possível
fazer com código puro. Agora sim, ele
terminou aqui esse segundo vídeo. Ele
levou um tempo bem maior, quase 50
minutos para editar o vídeo de 1
minuto50. Isso acontece porque nesse
processo de edição de estúdio, onde ele
envia o pedido lá para Higshifield, até
ela processar também as imagens, os
vídeos, voltar para o cloud Code, ele
montar tudo isso, leva um tempo maior.
Às vezes ele fica no looping apenas
esperando o processo terminar para ele
começar a montagem. Então é natural que
leve um tempo maior. Mas em relação à
sessão anterior que nós gastamos 238.000
tokens, aqui nós gastamos 420.000 tokens
ainda dentro do plano, uma sessão de
quase 1 hora. você gastar apenas isso
dentro do plano ainda. E lá na Higfield,
deixa eu ver quanto que nós já
consumimos. Eu estava no início da
sessão com 3.000 créditos, eu tinha
acabado de renovar o plano ultra e agora
eu estou aqui com 2906, ou seja, menos
de 100 créditos nós gastamos para poder
fazer esse vídeo que eu ainda não vi. Eu
já deixei aberto aqui. Voltando aqui na
pasta da edição do vídeo, nós vamos em
edições e agora tem essa nova pasta aqui
da Higsifit, que foi esse processo que
nós fizemos e já tá aqui dentro da
pasta. Eu vou ver agora junto com você.
Eu quero ver a qualidade. Eu já vi que
tem uma estética aqui diferente e eu vou
tocar ele. Enquanto a gente toca, eu vou
vendo a referência, o que que ele fez,
que eu gostei ou que eu não gostei. Tem
também a legenda que já aparece desde o
início. Então vamos ver. Agora dá para
editar um vídeo com um cara
profissional, sem abrir programa de
edição nenhum. Eu uso para isso quatro
peças. A primeira é o Cloud Cach rodando
o ele é o diretor. Ele lêu o que eu
quero, decide o que cada trecho do vídeo
precisa, chama ferenta certa e o que ela
deve fazer. E o 5.5 e aguenta um
trabalho com animação a primeiro corte
até o render, sem esquecer o que eu pedi
lá no começo. E a segunda peça é a
watchíde, um skill que dá olhos ao
cloud. Ele transcreve a minha fala
exato, tira os frames aqui
para
planejar todas as inserções de acordo
com erro ele cortou parte dos corrigir
isso que monta
faz as transmissões, os movimentos de
câmera, coloca texto na tela, decide
onde eu fico em cada qua,
esse recorte de papel do da legenda, eu
gostei mais do anterior, não sei vocês,
mas aqui tá parecendo um pouco mais
máquina de escrever, não tá? com efeito
de recorte de papel.
>> Eu mudo qualquer coisa depois sem
precisar refazer tudo de novo. E uma
dica que mudou os meus resultados em vez
de eu tentar descoucrier
que estav muito mais assim do que
qualquer descrição que eu pudesse
entregar para ele. E a quarta peça,
>> esses efeitos, você vê que na versão
anterior não tinha essa esse trimor dos
elementos que dá uma dinâmica no vídeo
inteiro. Agora já mudou para uma legenda
branca. A versão inicial era preta,
agora ficou branca.
com
recriou o logo da HF. É o conector da
Higfield com
>> essa abertura de papel. Isso é um vídeo
criado na Higfield. Ficou muito barato.
Eu achei que ia ficar mais caro. Menos
de R$ 100. Ah, perdão, menos de 100
créditos para você fazer um vídeo desse
tamanho, de 2 minutos com todos esses
elementos, né? É o conector da
Hickfield. Com essas outras
code e watch vídeo conectando agora com
a Ritfield, o vídeo já sai com qualidade
de
>> estúdio. Com ela, o Cláudio começa a
gravar porque não estava na gravação. O
objeto recortado em papel.
>> Aqui ele recortou o a minha luminária
que ficou ali do fundo,
>> a ilustração, a cena inteira,
>> imagem de vídeo. Nossa, isso aqui ficou
muito legal
>> aqui. Ele recriou o meu cenário aqui de
certa forma com o MacBook, a mesa. Isso
ficou muito bom.
>> Cena inteira fez o efeito do Thanos
aqui, né? Nessa parte que o vídeo ele
ganha cara de produção de estúdio. Então
essas são as quatro partes. Cloud Code é
o diretor, a watch Vídeo, os olhos, a
remotion, a mão que monta tudo. E a
imaginação desse projeto para qualidade
de estúdio é a Higfield. Inclusive esse
vídeo que você está vendo saiu de uma
gravação crua, passando por essas quatro
ferramentas.
Então aqui colocando lado a lado, nós
vemos aqui a criação feita puramente com
código. Então vou colocar aqui no mesmo
tempo. Tô aqui em 30 e 40 segundos e
aqui também 40 segundos. Então você vê a
recreação, algumas diferenças aqui, por
exemplo,
aqui ele fez um recorte de papel. Aqui
nessa primeira versão com código, você
vê que ele tá basicamente pegando as
imagens do fundo onde eu coloquei nas na
pasta de referência e colocando aqui e
usando elas numa disposição diferente.
Aqui com a Higfield ele já recriou todo
o processo, recriou todas as imagens de
referência. Aqui usou a remotion para
poder fazer esse overlay. Aqui como eu
não pedi no prompt, ele fez tudo com a
Higpit. Ele não usou a remotion para
fazer esses overlays. Eu poderia ter
pedido isso também no Prompt. Quando
você une essas skills, você pode ter os
efeitos tanto da Remotion quanto os
efeitos também da Higsifield. Inclusive,
esse processo você pode fazer um ajuste
dentro desse repositório para você poder
economizar dentro do plano da
Higgsfield, porque aqui eu achei muito
barato, foi 97 créditos que a gente
gastou para poder fazer essa animação
inteira. Tem inclusive um vídeo aqui
recriado que é esse efeito do Thanos que
ele fez no final. Todos esses recors de
papel foram muitos modelos aqui de
imagem, de geração de imagem, enquanto
aqui o efeito também, o resultado também
é muito bom. Então, no nível um, onde
você pode criar um vídeo com 5.5 desse
nível de qualidade, que é o que tá aqui
da esquerda, e também nesse nível de
qualidade aqui com a Rickfield, gastando
pouco, aqui é muito interessante quando
você quer ter uma estética diferente.
Aqui eu devo dizer também que com o
Oppus 5.
Muito bom. Aqui, por exemplo, se você me
mostrasse isso daqui e eu não soubesse
que não foi feito ah só com código, eu
nem reconheceria. E você pode ver também
que a legenda, a forma que foi criada,
ela tem uma sombra. Ou seja, essa
legenda não foi criada puramente só com
uma imagem estática. Ele fez cada frame
de cada legenda dessa e colocou uma
sombra no fundo. E a estética ficou
muito boa. Aqui eu não comentei quando
eu tava vendo o processo pelo
encadeamento do raciocínio do modelo
enquanto ele criava. Ele instalou esse
pack de letras na Remotion enquanto ele
tava fazendo. Ou seja, se você não tem
algum pacote de fonte instalado no seu
computador, ele instala durante o
processo. Mas os dois resultados muito
bons aqui. O recorte de papel feito pela
Higfield também me agradou muito. Foi a
estética que eu dei para ele. Você
poderia ter dado uma outra estética aqui
nesse finalzinho. É um efeito puramente
aqui com modelos de imagem aqui na maior
parte. Eu não pedi para ele recriar
nenhum tipo de vídeo realista que daria
para você fazer também. Eu já tenho
vídeo aqui no canal criando esses outros
modelos, mas o grande valor aqui desse
repositório, ele está exatamente em você
unir essas ferramentas onde você pode
ter total controle. com a Higfield aqui
nesse projeto que eu vou deixar para
vocês o link na descrição. Ele já vai
estar completo. Você tem o nível de
edição um que você pode fazer com essas
skills gratuitas, o nível de edição dois
com a Higfield, onde você pode ter e
recriar não só processos como esse, mas
vídeos mais realistas com o Cloud Opus
5.
todo esse efeito, esse controle visual e
você chegando a resultado com esses um
plano do Cloud Code, o plano Pro e uma
conta da Rickfield, você consegue criar
muitos vídeos. Aqui nesse processo
inteiro, durante todo o vídeo, eu gastei
menos de 40% da minha sessão diária e
sem créditos apenas no plano da
Higsfield. E na minha leitura, o que
muda aqui é a sua capacidade de
controle, de utilizar um modelo que já é
muito bom, muito robusto, e você poder
criar vídeo com código também, um
processo usando skills gratuitas e tendo
o maior controle também do seu plano. No
último vídeo que eu gravei mostrando
aqui a Higfield, muitas pessoas
perguntaram quanto que fica esse
processo e eu vi que tem também a forma
de você fazer com a API. Eu quero gravar
um vídeo aqui também mostrando como que
funciona. Tem um desconto também muito
interessante em relação ao uso aqui do
plano que eu tenho. E você pode ter o
controle e usar das duas formas. E na
hora de você mandar o prompt, você pode
inclusive estipular o quanto que você
quer gastar ali. Se você tem, por
exemplo, uma meta, você precisa criar 20
vídeos por semana, você pode definir
quanto que você quer gastar para cada
vídeo e ter uma edição também mais
equilibrada, porque quanto mais
inserção, quanto mais elementos você
cria, mais créditos você vai acabar
gastando. Então, dá para ter esse
controle também inicial antes de você
mandar cada requisição. E na medida que
você vai usando, e eu tô usando aqui já
quase dois meses, você vai também
entendendo como que você consegue ter
esse controle maior. Mas eu já usei com
Astra, já usei com Oppul 5.1, já usei
com Oppul 5. Agora também já fiz outras
coisas e na minha leitura, o Oppul 5.5
aqui tem sido o campeão, o melhor modelo
para você conectar com a Rickfield ou
para criar vídeo com código puro ou
criar vídeo mais criativo nessa
qualidade de estúdio. E se fizer sentido
para você, o link da Hixfield vai estar
aqui na descrição e também no comentário
fixado. Vale a pena você entrar lá,
conhecer, ver como que isso vai
funcionar no seu fluxo, instalar também
esse repositório e começar a editar os
seus vídeos com o Cloud Code e com a
Higfield. E nós iremos nos ver no
próximo.